[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
film independent presents I am your host
and moderator Carla ranada and I'd like
to thank our take this time to thank our
lead Partners the golden go Globe
Foundation my mouth is not working with
me today I don't know what's happening
anywh who um we are here to talk about a
fantas fabulous independent film called
memory which stars Miss Jessica Chastain
and Mr Peter sarsgard so welcome you
guys thank you so much hi for having us
hi so I watched the film and I was blown
away by your
performances both of you all I've seen
numerous things of your works in the
Zeitgeist of your career and you all are
excellent at giving these understated
nuanced performances that speak so loud
but say everything all at once but even
more so with this particular film with
Saul and Sylvia so I just want to get
into it real quick at the start talking
about how you built the Nuance
performances before for these two
characters especially for Saul because
he doesn't have a whole lot to say but
he
does yeah I mean what Saul wants is so
human that it was a joy to play I mean
he wants
connection um he doesn't want to be put
in the grave before he's dead he wants
life um he lives in the moment because
he can't remember the previous moment
you know and he meets this
woman who's who's got so much going on
but of course I forget her whole past a
lot of the time this is somebody who's
who's memory of what's happened to her
is really causing her problems in the
present and I'm of course somebody who
can't hold that memory with her so it's
a very interesting relationship and I
think for me just in terms of preparing
for it it just felt like I got out of
the way you know I had an uncle who had
dementia who I was close with I knew
something about it his was pretty mild
for
years um and I talk to people who had
dementia on the telephone because
it felt like a Kinder way you know it's
it's strange to meet someone and say I'm
studying the part of you that is
broken it's awkward and um these are
people that volunteered for through a
doctor and
uh yeah it was a joy to play him it's a
joy to play someone who wants
life it was a joy to watch Jessica can
you speak to how you crafted Sylvia for
a second
yeah I you know with Sylvia so much is
about how we meet her and how she walks
through her life and what she leads with
and she really leads with trauma she
leads with the memory of her past she
leads with
shame um and
and you know being a a sober person and
she has been for 13 years I had to
really fill out the blanks of what her
life has been like starting from when
she was a child the to make it as as
specific as possible you know the
questions of what exactly happened to
her um what was her relationship like
with her sister what did their parents
smell like what did their house look
like
[Music]
um what happened to school all of these
things sorry go ahead ask I was going to
say I didn't mean to interrupt you but
when you said what her parents smell
like that's such a very
specific objective and intention to have
that I can when you said that I could
totally see how you did that in my head
I flipped right back to the the film and
saw you do that I'm sorry please
continue I just got so excited when I
heard you say that well it's it's the
thing of like when you make something
feel as though you understand these
memories as your own
it help for it helps me play the
character like I didn't make certain
choices that I see on screen and they
happened because of the the preparation
I did so like even the idea of when
someone walks by Sylvia she moves back
she doesn't want to be touched like the
idea that her skin hurts when someone
touches her even her daughter I don't
you know she's not someone who's really
like a cuddling her daughter uh and when
you have this kind of uber
sensitivity to other human
beings how can you then learn to start
to open and start to lead your life
without putting the trauma in front of
you and I think it's so beautiful that
the way she's able to do that is to meet
someone who sees her new each moment by
each moment and they don't see her from
her past and what she's walking in with
they don't see Sylvia with shame he sees
her as she is in that moment and and you
become sometimes how someone looks at
you and she's starting to look at
herself the way Saul can see her there's
two thank you for for answering that for
me and elaborating on it that was a
beautiful answer thank you so much
there's two moments that really stick
out in my mind with Sylvia and Saul the
first one is in the park where she goes
Full Throttle and is like you don't
remember me why don't you remember me
and the for lack of a better way to say
it the attack dogness of the of the
Dogma that she comes at him with that
and he
never reciprocates it he stays in this
Zen Buddha kind of place because he more
so than anyone else recognizes where he
is so I say all of that to say did you
all improv that scene or was that all on
the page that you brought to the
performance on the page yeah that was a
very complete scene that scene was
really like it was very well written
there there is a scene yeah it was it
was like down
to I love that at the end I'm like well
if you say that that's something I did
then we can say that's something I did
like I'm going to you know it's it
because the the thing that I know is sa
is that my memory for things a long time
ago is pretty good I know where I went
to school I know all kinds of things
even my memory for recent things isn't a
disaster you know um
so it's it made me have to question my
own dementia in a way in that scene
where I'm going like I think I know who
I am and I think I'm a person that
doesn't do things like that and I have
no memory of having done that but you
seem like you really think I did it so
now I will become that and I I that's
something that we all do for each other
right you you think think you know who
you are but then the world mirrors
something else back at you right and it
might be accurate or it might just be
messing with your mind and you should
stick with what you think so that idea
was really played out so beautifully in
that scene because she's really the way
you come at me in the scene too is like
it's not just taking my head off it's
like oh cut off a fingernail and now
we're we're gonna have to go the finger
I'm like wait wait what we might need
Band-Aid we might need some stitches we
not we're not quite sure might need a
body bag yeah but also the wonderful way
that Michelle shoots is because we're
both in the shot at the same time I came
into that scene as Sylvia I was so
excited to finally get there to finally
like you know there's a sense of like
Glee of like this is my moment and then
to play the scene and I I I learned so
much actually watching the film
afterward
to play the scene and see the way Saul
is so kind of Zen and calm and the
difference in energy he doesn't match
her energy and then it completely all of
a sudden the power that she came in with
this Warrior I gonna fix this it in some
sense makes her feel victimized again
even though nothing's happened to her
but there's a there's an emotional loss
of like I can't even have this moment
and I didn't see that on the page I
didn't see that until I was in the scene
with Peter and that's the beautiful
thing about working with an actor who's
so open that you discover things about
your character you didn't anticipate I
mean the exact opposite of what's on the
page is also happening which is they're
connecting now it might seem like it's a
horrible connection but they're speaking
the truth both of them in the scene this
happened I don't think it happened okay
I okay I'm listening to I'm trying to
I'm listening and that kind of
interaction is I think something neither
of them have done that much of I've been
living by myself with my brother who
barely says anything to me you know and
and she's been living in this very
closeted world and
um I think this is like the beginning of
something even though it looks like the
end of something you know on some level
when I watch the movie
again
I agree with everything that both of you
said that's why I asked you about this
thing because I knew there was a lot to
it and I really want people who've seen
it to be able to get what was behind it
because I watch when I finished watching
it I was like I really need to know
about this scene the other scene I need
to know about is the one where he shows
up at your job and says he wants to talk
to you and y'all step outside and y'all
just in each other's faces looking in
each other's
faces when I tell you the emotion that
jumps off the screen and the energy that
jumps off the screen between the two of
you in that scene again I'm gonna ask
was that scripted or was that improved
and did he did did the director just let
the camera roll and get what he needed
to get talk to me about
it the kiss was scripted all of that was
scripted but we shot it twice Yeah we
actually shot it and he does this thing
where he builds in extra days at the end
so he's largely shooting this thing in
order and then he has a couple days at
the end for new scenes re shoots of
scenes things like that just a little
bit and he doesn't always use all of it
I guess but he I think that was one of
the ones where we were like oh let's go
back and do that scene one more
time so we did that whole bit on two
separate days I loved it it was it was
beautiful it was so so so so beautiful
um I want to talk about that song that
is I'm G call it Saul song for lack of a
better way to say it but it's literally
the title of it is called the wher sh
shade of fail um what is the meaning of
that song for Saul and then it ends up
having a double meaning for Saul and
Sylvia by the time the film
ends that's my wife is the meaning of
that song that song's totally connected
to my wife I say my wife loved the
Hammond Organ I just I said basically
she loves the song I play the song over
and over I think that song is my
connection to my wife and I do think my
wife is a real presence in the movie for
me you know it's it motivates a lot of
the different things that I do but what
ends up happening is you know he moves
through it and it become it it it winds
up at her feet you know so I think by
the end that song to me changes is into
not the song about my wife but the song
for connection you know and it's not
like at the of the movie you're like w
he's thinking about his wife you know
like it's it's um it's that love can do
that you can have all this love and the
person can pass away it's not going
anywhere can move on to someone else and
uh it's a it's a subtle thing that's in
the movie I think um you can tell me but
I like it it is subtle it is subtle but
just like you all like I said about you
all in your performances it's
understated but it's powerful and it
says a lot without saying anything at
all you know what I mean like you very
you very faintly hear the song The only
time you hear it really loudly is when
he's laying in the bed and the the phone
is right there and he's just hitting the
phone and putting it on repeat you know
I I and I love that that was the only
music that was in the film was that song
I just love that I love Nuance I love
specifity when it when it comes to to
these types of films um speaking of
which something that I thought was
interesting about Sylvia's character is
that she's 13 years sober she's got
three locks on the door like what's up
with her and threes in in her life like
the the three with the locks the three
with the 13 years sober the fact that
she she's she is tough but she's
vulnerable all at the same time which
struck me hard when you find Saul in the
street right and you turn your back to
him when I realized the film was taking
place in New York and this man was on
the ground and you turned your back I'm
like Jessica Chastain I know you didn't
turn your back on somebody that's
sitting on the ground in New York City I
know you didn't just I know you didn't
just do that back to him what do you
mean like when she first when you were
on the phone so you turned your back to
him when you were on the phone is
because she's with the daughter you mean
when the daughter comes out yeah no even
before the daughter came out you just
for a slight second you turned your back
you turned your back a couple of times
but it was enough for me to notice it
and I was like you in New York City and
you turning your back on somebody on the
ground I think I could always see him I
always I could turn to the side but I
think he was always in M no I see
someone who's hyper Vigilant in that
scene like okay take it take it easy
even when the brothers shows up and puts
him in the car I like she can't even be
next to him so yeah there's definitely
some kind of force field where she um
has a huge layer of protection a barrier
okay all right I'll take that when you
guys have the same y'all are laughing at
me you're funny um when you have the
scene with your parents whereas you and
sa and your daughter and your parents
and your sister and your sister finally
has your back for the first time ever in
your
life what did that feel like for Sylvia
because Sylvia all this time has been
saying this is my story this is what
happened why do you all keep saying it
did that this didn't happen and that I'm
making it up when you know that this is
true like why are you doing
that I mean that was an incredibly
painful scene I can't even talk about it
without getting emotional because I
think about about it's so painful to
film that
scene I know that it was painful to
watch and even the aftermath of it was
painful to watch where you're in the the
tub and you just like you just can't she
just can't find the words to even
express it watching it it felt like she
was experiencing grief relief like a
just a wave smage board of emotions that
couldn't have any words attached to them
you
know yeah I we keep we keep freezing on
the camera but also I think what um I
know you're saying relief and grief but
I think there's also betrayal there too
like I know the sisters has said
something but there's the Betrayal of
for years struggling on your own and um
you know her dealing with addiction and
abuse from other people and all of these
things and everyone treating her like
she's the crazy one and she's done all
these horrible things and she's a a
problem for the family you know an
obstacle to the family she's the problem
child so yes is the relief of finally
the truth is out there but it's also the
Betrayal of for 40
years she's
been ignored and denied that moment so
it feels it's a it's a great betrayal I
think also from the sister um
of that whole life that they've had
together but the beautiful way that
Meritt plays it is you see too that
she it be just by chance of living in
the house and being around it is was com
was
absolutely abused herself and the
marriage she finds herself in and and
how she walks through the world is is as
a damaged human being as well yeah
Meritt does a beautiful job so does Josh
they every every all of you all it's a
really strong um cast of characters that
are very understated and strong all the
way through from beginning to end
whether their mouths are open and
speaking or not so I appreciated that at
some point in the film I heard someone
say the past is unstable and so is the
present what does that mean for both of
you on the other side of this
project that the past is who says that
the past and the present are both
unstable
the past is unstable and so is the
present tell you that for me
um you know the past is always a story
that I'm making as I go along you know
and it kind of becomes that for all of
us and that's one of
the the unfortunate things about the
past right that we the way we remember
is all a little bit
different um I always feel like the only
thing I really have is the present
moment and the present moment is the
only place that's stable for me and it's
what I do for a living and on some level
you know like homework is the past which
I then mostly forget my I used to have
this great acting teacher who really was
the main person who helped me learn how
to do this her name was Penny Allen and
I would go and work with her and we
alcino is acting teacher as well totally
yeah yeah I would go and I would like
write through the we'd write up the
script right just saying all kinds of
stuff and then I never ever would go
back and read any of it I would go and
do a scene and I'd be like oh I should
go see what we wrote down and then i'
like ah because that's that's not right
now that's just something I thought then
and maybe it's in there somewhere
rattling around you know I've thought
about it and uh yes so for to to me
that's why I do what I do is because I
feel very confident and stable in the
present
reality how about you
Jessica yeah I think the only thing that
is stable and true is that nothing is
stable and
true is that we can think we have
control
over anything but we really we're we're
at the mercy of every moment and the
second you accept that I guess it's
accepting that we're all going to die
yeah the second you AC accept that we
really you're not in control I think
easier life is to live yeah that's one
beautiful thing about Saul that I just
loved was he you know the idea where
he's just like listen I got like half an
hour left of good time in my life where
I'm gonna be somebody you want to hang
out with don't you kind of want to just
hang out with me a good time have a good
time I got half an hour and send me
away let's just talk about I I saved
this for the end um because I didn't
want the whole conversation to center
around the subject
but let's just talk about in in rounding
out the conversation about the dementia
part of it and the softness and the
humanity that is given to the character
of Saul in this film he is not in a
place where he doesn't know who he is
he's not in a place where he doesn't
know that that's not his house you know
he may forget what he did yesterday or a
couple of days before but he's very he's
very present but not at the agitation
stages of dementia where they they get
angry when they can't grasp on to what
the past was and I want to know from
both of you how important it was for you
all to treat this character that way
with that type of respect and dignity
within the confines of the script and
your crafting of these characters and
the relationship between Saul and
Sylvia I not only think about the people
who have demen
that are going through experiences that
are unique each and every one of them
you know it is from having talked to Dr
White House who I worked with on this
film he the first thing he told me was
like it's make it as individual as every
character that you play this affects
everyone differently and that's the
first thing to know the second thing
that I really thought about was the
families of the people who have dementia
and that there would be some real value
in playing someone who's a more at the
beginning of this experience because I
think this is actually the time that
some people even go through where
everyone's in denial about it oh we
forgot that again got lost outside okay
you know people limp along for quite
some time without acknowledging what it
is so this is what it can look like this
is one example and um you know it's also
that just because you've now labeled it
doesn't mean
there's a bunch of restrictions that you
need to apply to this person they could
if they were living their life parts of
it in a way that made sense and worked
for them before they can probably do it
today don't need to like stop them from
doing one of the guys that I talked to
on the phone weekly who had dementia
drove was still driving last time I
talked to him and he was a guy who had
Post-it notes around his house so he
said I said you know what do you do if
you get lost and he said before I leave
it goes into my thing my map thing I
have two map things I know to follow
that you know there'll might come come a
time where he doesn't know to follow the
Blue Line anymore and that you reassess
but to treat people where they are where
they actually are in their lives and
there's a group called reimagining
dementia that um Dr White House is part
of and they're doing just that like
let's reimagine let's not just take what
we've seen in movies which we tend to
imitate in life
unconsciously but like what is is your
specific situation with dementia how are
you going to reimagine it you
know and also you personal connection
because your uncle and my uncle had
dementia and he was
probably the the most joyful person in
my family so this is a guy who to the
last day of his life was never had the
anger stuff that I encountered he just
wasn't a guy that got that way and this
was a guy who had
CTE right
so that's frequently associated with
violent outbursts but no he he wasn't
like that so just to just to because
doctors have to treat illnesses we have
to label them and group them but this
one in particular is a spectrum of
experience did you have anything to add
Jessica
uh well I mean in playing Sylvia I think
I think it she she spends her life
taking care of others in terms of her
job and that's what made sense to me
like why does she go outside in the
morning and get his phone and call the
brother I mean she is someone why does
she go back into the park and find him
um when she thinks he did these terrible
things she is someone who cares about
other people and and wants to protect
other people even even when they the
world hasn't protected her she is a good
person
uh and I think because of what she does
for a living where she works I think it
makes perfect sense that she would see
Saul as a human being um separate from
uh dementia but separate from the
condition that he has just like he sees
her as a human being separate from her
history and her trauma right she is not
trauma and I am not dementia we even say
things like this when we speak about
people sometimes they'll say oh that SK
schizophrenic of that person who happens
to have schizophrenia we we tend to or
schito skitso I mean we tend to use
these kind of labels to just file people
into different sections of course being
an actor that's the opposite of what we
do exactly I think that's a really good
point Peter that this is um a disease
that shouldn't be labeled you know and
we do have a tendency and a habit of
labeling things it's just a part it's a
different part of life and a different
chapter of life and some people live
through that and some people don't I
personally am someone who has lived
through it a few times so I understand
and have empathy and patience and love
and care for my family members that um
experiened that so watching this film
was a very personal experience for me
from that vantage point and so and
closing out our convers I'd like to
thank both of you for bringing such
humanity and respect and dignity to that
disease by portraying it in a way that
we don't often see on film or if ever so
thank you so much for that I appreciate
you both and also I didn't want the
conversation to end without
congratulating you Peter on your um best
actor award at the Venice International
Film
Festival I love that congratulations I'm
hoping that this is not the last I'm
speaking to you guys about this nor will
it be the last that anybody hears anyone
speaking about the film because it's
brilliant and it was beautiful and I
appreciate both of you and what you did
in the confines of the film thank you so
much very very much pleasure to talk to
you yes absolutely I am Carla Rado the
moderator you have been part of film
independent presents and we will see you
next time
bye-bye